time
fascinates not just physicists
fascinates everyone
and yet it is a relative concept
for example
if you travel
faster and faster and faster time slows
down more and more and more if you
travel at the speed of light time simply
stops
if you look at the equations of physics
it's striking that time can go forwards
or backwards the questions of physics
don't distinguish because of this many
people believe that you can travel into
the past
because there's nothing in the equations
of physics that forbids you doing that
it is quite possible that we could in
principle travel back in time so long as
we do not introduce any inconsistency
with the future